okay so we are finally ready to
express the quadratic approximation of a
multivariable function in vector form so
i have the whole thing written out here
where f is the function that we are
trying to approximate x naught y naught
is the constant point about which we are
approximating and then this entire
expression is the quadratic
approximation which i've talked about in
past videos and if it seems very
complicated or absurd or you're
unfamiliar with it and just dissecting
it real quick this over here is the
constant term this is just going to
evaluate to a constant everything over
here
is the linear term
because it just involves taking a
variable multiplied by a constant and
then the remainder
every one of these components will have
two variables multiplied into it so like
x squared comes up and x times y and y
squared comes up so that's the quadratic
term
quadratic
now to vectorize things first of all
let's write down the input the input
variable x y as a vector and typically
we'll do that with a bold faced x to
indicate that it's a vector and its
components are just going to be the the
single variables x and y the non-bold
faced so this is the vector representing
the variable input and then
correspondingly a bold faced x with a
little subscript o x naught is going to
be the constant input the single point
in space
near which we are approximating
so when we write things like that this
constant term simply enough is going to
look like evaluating your function at
that that bold faced x naught
so that's probably the easiest one to
handle now the linear term this looks
like a dot product and if we kind of
expand it out as the dot product it
looks like we're taking the the partial
derivative of f with respect to x and
then the partial derivative with respect
to y and we're evaluating both of those
at that boldfaced x naught input
x naught as its input now each one of
those partial derivatives is multiplied
by variable minus constant numbers so
this looks like taking
the dot product here i'm going to erase
the word linear
we're taking with x
minus x naught
and y
minus
y naught this is just expressing the
same linear term but as a dot product
but the convenience here is that this is
totally the same thing as saying the
gradient of f
gradient of f that's the vector that
contains all the partial derivatives
evaluated at the special input
x naught
and then we're taking the dot product
between that and the variable vector
bold faced x
minus
x naught
since when you do this component wise
bold face to x minus x naught if we kind
of think here it'll be x the variable
minus x naught the constant y the
variable minus y not the constant which
is what we have up there so this
expression kind of vectorizes the whole
linear term and now the beef here the
hard part how are we going to how are we
going to vectorize this quadratic term
now that's what i was leading to in the
last couple of videos where i talked
about how you express a quadratic form
like this with a matrix and the way that
you do it i'll just kind of scroll down
to give us some room the way that you do
it is we'll have a matrix
whose components are all of these
constants it'll be this one half times
the second partial derivative evaluated
there and i'm just going to for
convenience sake i'm going to just take
one half times the second partial
derivative with respect to x and leave
it as understood that we're evaluating
it at this point and then on the other
diagonal you have one half times the
other
kind of partial derivative with respect
to y two times in a row
and then we're going to multiply it by
by this constant here but this term kind
of gets broken apart into two different
components if you'll remember in the
quadratic form video it was always
things whereas a and then two b and c as
your constants for the quadratic form so
if we're interpreting this as two times
something
then it gets broken down
and on one corner it shows up as f
x y
and on the other one kind of one half f
x y so like both of these together are
going to constitute the entire mixed
partial derivative
and then the way that we express the
quadratic form is we're going to
multiply this by well by what well the
first component is whatever the thing is
that's squared here so it's going to be
that x minus
x naught
and then the second component is
whatever the other thing squared is
which in this case is
y
minus
y naught
and of course we take that same vector
but we put it in on the other side too
so
so let me make a little bit of room
because this is going to be wide
so we're going to take that same vector
and then kind of put it on its side so
it'll be x minus
x naught as the first component and then
y minus y naught as the second component
but it's written horizontally and this
if you multiply out the entire matrix is
going to give us the same expression
that you have up here and if that seems
unfamiliar if that seems you know how do
you go from there to there
check out the video on quadratic forms
or you can check out the article where
i'm talking about the quadratic
approximation as a whole i kind of go
through the computation there now this
matrix right here is almost the hessian
matrix this is why i made a video about
the hessian matrix it's not quite
because everything has a one-half
multiplied into it so i'm just going to
kind of take that out and we'll remember
we have to multiply a one-half in at
some point but otherwise it is the
hessian matrix which we denote with a
kind of bold-faced h bold-faced h and
emphasize that it's the hessian of f the
hessian is something you take of a
function and like i said remember each
of these terms we should be thinking of
as evaluated on the special input point
evaluating it at that special
you know boldfaced x naught input point
i was just kind of too lazy to write it
in each time the x naught y not x not y
not x not y naught all of that
but what we have then is we're
multiplying it on the right by this
whole vector is the variable vector
bold-faced x
minus
bold-faced x-naught
that's what that entire vector is and
then we kind of have the same thing on
the right you know boldface vector x
minus
x-naught
except that we transpose it we kind of
put it on its side and the way you
denote that you have a little t there
for transpose so this term
captures all of the quadratic
information that we need
for the approximation
so just to put it all together if we go
back up when we put the the constant
term that we have the linear term and
this quadratic form that we just found
all together what we get is that the
quadratic approximation of f which is a
function we'll think of it as a vector
input bold-faced x
it equals the function itself evaluated
at you know whatever point we're
approximating near
plus the gradient of f which is kind of
it's vector analog of a derivative
evaluated at that point so this is a
constant vector
dot product with the
with the variable vector
x minus the constant vector
x naught
that whole thing plus one half
the
we'll just copy down this whole
quadratic term up there
the
variable
minus
the constant
multiplied by the hessian which is kind
of like an extension of the second
derivative to multi-variable functions
and we're evaluating that no let's say
we're evaluating it at the at the
constant
at the constant
x naught
and then on the right side we're
multiplying it by the variable x minus
x naught
and this this is the quadratic
approximation in vector form and the
important part is now it doesn't just
have to be of a two variable input you
could imagine plugging in a three
variable input or a four variable input
and all of these terms make sense you
know you take the gradient of a four
variable function you'll get a vector
with four components you take the
hessian of a four variable function you
would get a four by four matrix and all
of these terms make sense and i think
it's also prettier to write it this way
because it looks a lot more like a
taylor expansion in single in the single
variable world you have you know a
constant term plus
the value of a derivative times x minus
a constant plus one half what's kind of
like the second derivative term was kind
of like taking an x squared but this is
how it looks in the vector world so in
that way it's actually maybe a little
bit more familiar than writing it out in
the full you know component by component
term where it's easy to kind of get lost
in the weeds there so
full vectorized form of the quadratic
approximation of a scalar valued
multivariable function
boy is that a lot to say